وسطنا العالم كله مو بس العرب يعني
مشغولين باخبار زلزال تركيا وسوريا
تفاجانا بخبر عن زلزال في بافلو في
نيويورك اليوم زلزال بقوه 3.8 درجات على
مقياس
زلزال بتتعرض له الولايه من اربعين عام
زلزال نيويورك على زلزال جديد تسجل اليوم
في تركيا بقوه 5.7 على زلزلين امس
المدمرين طبعا رعبوا العالم خاصه مع اخبار
الهزات الارتداديه اللي سجلت لزلزال تركيا
وسوريا واللي تقدر بالمئات في تركيا بس في
310 هزات ارتداديه تسجلوا من وقت الزلزال
الكبير وبعض الهزات وصلت ايران والعراق
والاردن ولبنان وحتى جرينلاند المركز
الاوروبي المتوسطي لرصد الزلازل قدر في
خريطه لايف كده بينشرها على موقعه انه
خلال 48 ساعه الماضيه في 245 زلزال ضربوا
العالم وهذول قوتهم اعلى من اربعه على
مقياس ريختر طبعا كل هذه الاخبار عامله
حاله رعب للناس هل الرقم هذا الطبيعي 245
زلزال في العالم في 48 ساعه هل هذه
الزلازل لها علاقه ببعض طيب معهد رسم
الزلازل الايطاليه لانه سبب زلزال سوريا
وتركيا تحرك صفيحه الاناضول خمسه امتار
خلال عده ثواني هل هذا كمان سبب باقي
زلازل العالم